all right baby yes baby welcome back
again
thank you so the baby is how old now
she is almost five months
she will be five months on
oh she just turned five months on the
13th
november january february no wait
november december january february
and where's she been for those five
months she's been in a foster home
is about like 30 minutes outside of
downtown l.a i think not too far
yeah she's been in a temporary foster
placement but i found out
yesterday my caseworker called me and
told me
that the judge signed the
paper and they're going to ship her back
home to tennessee to live with my aunt
that has custody of my other daughter
so it's pretty exciting i guess to
reunite them
yeah so that's she'll have a nice home
a nice home where have she been just
like in a hospital basically um
she's just been in like a temporary
placement foster home
out here have you been visiting her um i
got to do
one visit over the phone with her and
then i had lost my phone so i lost
contact with my
caseworker and i lost contact with the
foster
mom so yesterday i finally got back in
contact with my case manager and
that's when he gave me the news that the
judge already signed the paper
now it's just a matter of finding out
when
the exact date they're going to ship her
back she's going to your aunt yes
which is better than scheduled better
than skid row it's better than
the other choice which was adoption
and because like in the state of
california
when a child goes into their system they
have to figure out pretty much like a
permanent placement by six months
they wanna you know what i'm saying have
them like stable or at least
what they think is going to be stable
forever you know
so you only got six months from zero to
six months and
if you don't get it together by then
then basically it's
adoption or family members
does this motivate you to want to get
clean and get back to your
child um it does it does
it does i mean it's still hard
but at least i know that
you know i know my daughter lives good
my daughter that already lives with my
aunt she lives good
she has nothing to worry about they take
great care of her
she's you know i'm saying she's a good
kid
she don't need nothing want nothing
she's spoiled rotten
at least knowing that she's going back
there though kind of gives me the
the hope and the joy you know i'm saying
maybe one day
i can conquer it and
get them both back and go you know i'm
saying really not with them but
i don't know it's still going to be hard
to be honest are you back using again
i have been like not constantly but like
you know
like occasionally uh
i have i have
more than i should have more than i
should be period i shouldn't be doing it
at all but
i have a few times recently
so this is your second child or this is
my second child
second well technically it's my third i
miscarried my first and then i had zoe
and now i have zara
and you're home 26 just turned 26
uh the 12th friday the 12th
yes so where do you see your life going
from here darling um
well you can stay down here and have
more kids
i mean i do like la but when they do
send her back
when that day comes and they actually do
ship her back
if i do leave la i'll probably just go
back to vegas for right now
and try to you know i'm saying at least
like
get some money up i don't know i got job
offers out there like doing movies and
stuff
before i came before i got pregnant so
doing movies
yeah like um you know in las vegas they
do like the little street movies on
fremont
like not no big production film like
fox or nothing like that but
i did get a couple like little offers to
do a few little small movies and stuff
so i'm sure that offers
those offices still on the table and if
not then there will be way more to come
in vegas so at least if i go back to
vegas i could
go and do a few you know what i'm saying
little jobs and
stack some money up at least to go visit
them in tennessee
or you know it just it's a progress a
work in progress like i don't want to
say i'm going to do something
and then i'm not going to do it you know
it's a good
policy i don't got no crystal ball so i
can't tell you what i'm going to do in
a month what do you what do you think of
this lifestyle that you've carved out
where you're living on the street and
you're doing drugs and you're
getting pregnant but not having honestly
i feel like [ __ ] for not having my kids
not being there for them and stuff but
at the same time i don't want to say i
regret anything because
everything that i've done up until this
day and still from this day forward
has made me become the person i am and i
think i'm a pretty good person
minus you know what i'm saying the drugs
and my past
what i've been through but i think all
overall i'm a pretty
pretty good person i got a big heart
i'm strong-minded
except for you know my downfall which is
the drugs but
i mean i've been through some [ __ ] so
that's kind of just like
my coping skill my my go-to that's all i
know that's all i've ever known
my mom was a drug addict so therefore i
grew up
i did my first drug with my mom you know
so that's
all i've ever known from a young young
age like the age of
i started smoking weed at six i started
doing harder drugs at nine
like pills then i started doing way
harder drugs at
12 11 you know i'm saying coke and
mess and molly and [ __ ] like that so
that's basically
like that's all i've ever known to do
when when i feel
down going back to tennessee wouldn't
get you away from the drugs because it
definitely would not get me away from
the drugs but it would definitely
it would definitely be if i did go back
to tennessee and i was able to you know
i'm saying be closer to them
and live there and
be stable it would definitely be more
motivation
for me knowing that you know what i'm
saying they're both there and it's just
that much
that much closer for me to get them back
or that much easier for me to be able to
go and
play with them whenever i want to or go
and you know i'm saying hold them and
touch them and hug them and [ __ ]
yeah yeah something needs to change in
your it does it
and i pray i pray i pray i
can conquer this but
i'm grateful for every you know i'm
saying every day that goes by that
i don't think about it or every day that
goes by that i can
just get up and just smile like today
i'm feeling myself
like i feel like great today you know
what i'm saying but
some days i just be like i feel like i
just want to die like i want to end
everything
like i'm a piece of [ __ ] like i'm not
good enough like
like it's not worth it anymore
but then i think about them
and that's the only that's my rock
that's what you know what i'm saying
it's my motivation is there a lot of
guilt
there is
there is there's a lot of guilt
i'm just thankful that
that god let me carry them full term and
let them be born
and they were healthy and
beautiful and strong and alive
and you know it's a miracle it really
is it really is it's
it's all i can do is thank god
because i don't know what i would do if
i didn't have this
you know what i'm saying if i if i
couldn't say like
oh i have these two beautiful [ __ ]
daughters
that god gave me i don't know why he
gave them to me
i probably didn't deserve them i know i
didn't deserve them
but they're here
they're alive they're healthy they're
beautiful
they're strong yeah but you haven't seen
them
no but i mean
just like i had a miscarriage with my
first child
because my baby daddy was abusive my
same baby daddy my first daughter's baby
daddy
abusively drugged drove me down a
three-mile gravel driveway beat the [ __ ]
out of me on christmas day i miscarried
his child
he came home that night from robbing
people i gave him his child in the
styrofoam cup he threw it over the fence
in the snow
that's heartless that's cold how could
you do that you could see the little
fetus inside the sack
i didn't go to no hospitals i didn't i
did it all by myself
just like delivering zara i had zara
right here on gladys
in a tent by myself i zip-tied her
umbilical cord
i sucked the the mucus and [ __ ] out of
her mouth with my mouth because i didn't
have the sucking bulb thing
you know that's that's an experience
that
i'm sure not a lot of people can say
they've
experienced and it's crazy it's insane
as much as i think about it
but it's a beautiful experience and i
wouldn't trade it for the world
like i'm glad i got to do that
i feel like that made me that much
closer we had that much of a stronger
bond you know me my job
me and my daughter have this bond that's
i don't have with nobody else not even
my first daughter
at all i've never had this like it's
just the feeling that
[Music]
it's amazing even though i i haven't
seen
her since they took her from me in the
hospital when she was four days old
i haven't seen her except for on video
chat one time and i have two pictures
that
the dcfs worker sent me but
i feel like i can feel her
you know what i'm saying like when she's
hurt or when she cries i feel like i can
feel it
like i can feel her emotions
i can feel her pain
i just everything i feel like my
daughters go through
especially my my youngest daughter i
feel like
i go through it with them even though i
don't you know
like i don't know when my daughters go
to the hospital and get their shots i
don't know
they don't tell me [ __ ] like that but
i can almost guarantee you
those days that they have went to the
hospital and gotten shots or have been
sick
or have you know what i'm saying just
felt like [ __ ]
i felt like [ __ ] with them
those days that they're all happy and i
can feel it
i can feel it and with everything you've
been through in your life what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned
just
um to just stay
strong and and do the right thing
you know you don't want to go down this
road you don't want to end up on skid
row out here it's not a pretty
place it's it's you don't want to be out
here doing these drugs
just seeing these people out here high
like this like
it's not it's not pretty a lady i just
seen on the news a lady stole a forklift
and ran from the police and a forklift
high off drugs
then when the police chased her down and
caught her
she opened fired on the police and shot
the police in the face
the police lived but of course they kill
her you know
but i've seen a bunch of [ __ ] like these
drugs out here
they [ __ ] people up and some of them
don't come back
some of them get high one time and be
hot for the rest of
eternity and it's [ __ ] up
you might you might go think you're
smoking a blunt of some
good-ass weed with somebody and it'd be
a pre-roll or some [ __ ] you know
and they drug you and it'd be some sherm
or some
what's that other drug called flakka or
you know [ __ ] like
i don't know i got drugged off of some
sherm one time in vegas and i don't
remember
four entire days from that [ __ ] i didn't
even know what sherm was never heard of
it never seen it
but i know i woke up black and blue
outside of or at a homeless man's
camp behind a prison high barbed wire
fence
across the street from palace station
casino i don't know how i got there
i thought i came there with people
apparently i came there by myself
destroyed this man's camp took his
blanket in his pillow and went to sleep
i woke up black and blue i found that
i've been raped
robbed beaten all type of [ __ ] in four
days
and i thought i was just smoking a
pre-roll with some dude at the casino
you know it's just scary
it really is my homeboy he just died out
here a couple of weeks ago
his name was moon he was 38 years old he
just got out of prison
he shoots up while he shot up
this girl his friend she
shot him up with fentanyl and crystal
mixed together and it killed him
he was at my house that morning laying
on my bed asleep
fine perfectly fine just hours before he
died
that shit's scary you know
you never know like what's gonna happen
you never know what these people are
giving you
and a lot of these people out here are
sick sick in the head they just do [ __ ]
people just i don't know what it makes
them feel
i guess some kind of satisfaction but i
don't see how you know
that's some pretty wicked [ __ ]
if you ask me
i just i don't know
i don't know i just really hope that i
could um
conquer this and
be strong enough to stay clean and
get my babies back and or at least be
closer to them
and you know what i'm saying show them
what my mom didn't show me
show them what a good life is instead of
the life i had
because that's the last thing i want to
do is let my kids live any type of the
life i had
at all i had my good days when i was a
kid but
it wasn't very many of them you know my
mom was a drug addict
and a prostitute and i raised her kids
and
i never got to be that you know what i'm
saying i just don't want
my kids to have to turn to let me go get
high because my mom's a piece of [ __ ]
why isn't she here you know
like i just want to show them like
even if i'm not there i'm trying you
know
i'm putting forth some type of effort
i'm not
gonna make them any promises that i
can't keep
like my mom used to tell me oh i promise
you i'm not doing nothing i'm
but she'll be high as [ __ ] picking up
[ __ ] off the carpet all the time
like clearly you're high as [ __ ] mom you
don't have to lie to us
you know
but when she was telling me that [ __ ] i
wasn't i was never old enough to realize
like man this [ __ ] is just lying in my
face you know
i was just a little kid like my daughter
is five six
you know and that [ __ ] hurts now that
i'm older now that my mom's gone and
you know saying i don't experience all
that
it hurts me more that i don't have my
kids
because of going through typical [ __ ]
like that like
i don't i just don't want them to
experience that [ __ ]
and it's bad enough neither one of my
kids got their fathers in their lives
i never had a father and that really
hurt me
by itself [ __ ] the drugs [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying my mom being a
prostitute and a crackhead all that [ __ ]
it hurt me
growing up being a little girl not not
having
i couldn't be daddy's little princess
which is every little girl's dream you
know
like oh i want to be daddy's princess
every girl wants that growing up every
girl
and i don't it's bad enough my kids
aren't gonna have that
unless they're with my aunt my uncle
that my daughter lives with then they'll
have you know
mommy and daddy but that's not mommy and
daddy at the end of the day
it could be i guess disguise to them as
that
but one day they're going to grow up and
and
and they're gonna understand like this
is not your real mommy and daddy
and they're gonna start asking questions
well where is my real mommy and daddy
and
i don't want my daughters to be old
enough to understand that grow up
and start asking them questions and and
maybe i'm dead somewhere in a ditch
because i got high on the wrong day from
i got the wrong drugs from the wrong
person that day and
and killed myself you know what i'm
saying i don't want to i don't want to
be that i don't wanna i don't know how i
would answer
to god or how i would explain that
when that time came you know what i'm
saying that that's probably the hardest
thing for me
how would my kids feel would they feel
like i felt when my mom died and i read
her body on facebook
probably not they'll probably feel way
worse because my mom was there for me
even though [ __ ] we was running doing
drugs together you get
breaking the law together going to jail
together like that was my best friend
she was my ride-or-die
regardless of whatever my family ever
said about her i love my mom
she was a piece of [ __ ] mom but
she was my best friend she was all i had
my kids i haven't got to grow up and
experience nothing with them
unfortunately my first daughter i lost
her a couple months old this daughter i
lost her at four days old
it's it'd be way way harder for me
at the end you know i'm saying if
something happened to me
i don't know what how how i'd live with
myself
or if i could kill my ghost if i die you
know what i'm saying like i'd do that
because that [ __ ] would hurt me
i know it hurts me to not have my mommy
anymore
every day
every day i miss my mom
i just want to grow up and be some kind
of a mom
or at least show them you know i do love
them
yeah all right baby thank you for coming
in again
i wish you the best of luck spend some
time with your daughter
you